:
un président américain venu
déposer des fleurs sur un
mémorial de victimes froidement
La visite de Joe Biden était
très attendue par cette
communauté encore gravement
marquée par la tuerie de samedi.
"Nous devons refuser
de vivre dans un pays, dit-il,
se faire tuer avec des armes
de guerre en faisant leurs
courses."
Une arme de guerre que
le tireur aurait o
(en anglais)eillé,
dit-elle, il ne l'était pas."
Ce n'es Ce n'es Ce n'es Ce n'e,
mais toute la communauté noire
aux États-Unis qui est éb
par la haine raciale.ais)
"Il faut que ceci stimuleation,
dit Kathy Hochul, faire toutce e
pour éradiquer ce mal qu'est
la suprématie blan
Deborah Freeman a vu
(en anglais)'il s'est retrouvé
devant un jeune homme blanc
allongé qui se protégeait,
il s'est excusé et a continué
à tirernoires. noires. noires. "
Le supermarché Tops, inauguré
en 2003 ,est le coeur de cette
communauté peu nantie.
Deborah Freeman y a travaillé
pendant des années. Ce qui l'a
le plus choquée, c'est la façon
dont le suspect a été arrété.
Les gens continuent à déposer
des fleurs, les prêtres viennent
parler d'amour et de pardon.(en)
"On va faire ce qu'on fait
d'habitude, dit-elle, être
au-dessus."
On parle de résilience
avec un sentiment de plus
en plus amer.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Buf